hi i'm jade i'm 18 years old and i'm
part of the gen z generation my name is
lindsay i'm 27 years old and i am part
of the millennial generation
my name is terence i am 65 years old and
i'm part of the boomer generation
[Music]
i would define cheating both as anything
physical
emotional wise mentally wise for example
even if
my partner is texting like some other
girl and i'm uncomfortable
with it i would consider that cheating
definitely
sleeping with someone else anything
intimate like sometimes intimacy doesn't
always have to be
sexual it's not just a physical thing i
think it's
involved emotionally
mentally
i personally can't date someone when you
cheated
just because a relationship is all about
trust and if i don't trust that person
even a smidge bit then i don't think i
can be in a relationship with them
i feel like i wouldn't totally say no
knowing that that you can't judge people
off of their past relationships
but i would definitely make a note of it
personally i feel like i
i could but i mean i think that that
there's always that
that nagging thing in the back of your
mind i think it would be hard
somewhat to to to build that trust
i believe it can be forgiveness is a big
thing
but it's an important it's an important
thing uh for people
to be able to move forward trust and
forgiveness are two different things
you can be forgiven but still have to
earn that trust
back i think i believe cheating is
something that can be forgiven
i'm not saying i'd stay in the
relationship with my partner if i got
cheated on
more that i would break up with him i
would forgive him for cheating on me but
i won't forget i don't think i would
ever forget i'm really big on
trust if i feel like that that kind of
betrayal i just couldn't trust you again
and i'm always gonna be looking at you
like
where you at you know are you with
whoever you know so
for me for me it can't be forgiven
of course i want to know if my partner
cheated on me
not saying i would stay in a
relationship with them of course i break
up with them it's good to know
um whether or not they knew what they
did was wrong
i don't think it's necessary i mean
nobody's perfect right i mean
everybody has faults and flaws and
different things
and the older i get the more i feel like
i'm
able to allow that give that grace
more to people and things that that i
may feel like i've been wronged in
they do say ignorance is bliss but
i'd rather you just tell me like i would
just rip the band-aid off and from there
we can figure it out
because at some point you're gonna find
out i mean we could be old and great
you know somebody the secret come out i
don't know but i think i'd rather know
then than look dumb
that's hard to say because that's such a
like personal thing
you know at least to me i feel like you
know sharing your body like that is just
super
it's just super personal and intimate
but emotionally too can be
even more damaging if they cheated on me
emotionally
it would be that they're in love with
them that they love that other person
i'd rather it be
like strictly shallow i think
emotionally would be worse because
you're giving
giving all of this
what i feel would be worse is that if my
partner
cheated on me with one person over a
long period of time
just because if my partner was with that
person over a long period of time
that means that they really are in love
with that other person
obviously hurt by both but one person
for sure i definitely would feel like
[Music]
the hit in the gut would be a little bit
harder than like just multiple
you know over a certain amount of time
one affair going
on for a long time
is worse that shows to me
an issue with that person itself it
seems like a deeper
problem between yeah both
with people
the thought of cheating because i see i
see the aftermath how it just devastates
the you know the other party i would
never like i said i barely want to be
with one person i'm not trying to be out
here with multiple you know on the
sneaky sneaky it's like tit for tat
you know um you did this so i'm gonna do
that
i don't think it's love i feel like a
lot of people in my generation are like
if i get cheated on hit them back harder
um do something that will affect them
even more
personally i wouldn't um i feel like the
way to handle that situation is to just
move on
something i believe that people get
wrong about my generation when it comes
to cheating
is that we all do it i know that it's
pretty common
but i swear there's some loyal guys and
girls out there who are gonna treat you
right
just takes a matter of time finding that
right person for you
we do get kind of like a stigma of just
being you know not faithful
you know i don't think i don't i don't
think that's true these generations get
older we learn
and you know we really just want to be
with one person i think that
you know i think for for our generation
we were kind of raised
in an old-fashioned type of way then
there were a lot of people that were
dissatisfied with those
norms for myself my wife and i you know
we've been married
for a long time being with one person
for a long time and
and loving them and respecting them and
just
experiencing life with them
pretty awesome
okay